[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau 7,8 journal
sur tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 22 mai
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition 85000 euros c'est le montant
total des prêts d'honneur financé par
yveline coopération internationale et
développement
trois conventions ont été signées en ce
sens à l'hôtel du département à
versailles
ces prêts ont été octroyés à des
entrepreneurs agissant en faveur de
l'afrique les précisions à suivre le 7
mai 2010 est emmanuel macron et est élu
président de la république
un an après quel bilan tirer at-il
révolutionner la politique est tenu ses
promesses et il le président des riches
comme le qualifient certains de ses
adversaires et nous poserons ces
questions à stéphane manceau professeur
de droit public à lui vécu
et puis le portrait de la semaine et en
musique rencontre avec la djette salomé
le lui alias pompiers de paris cette
versaillaise de 28 ans s'est lancé dans
le monde de la nuit il y a deux ans elle
nous l'avons suivi lors d'une soirée
parisienne 11e round de la grève à la
sncf vous le savez les cheminots ont
entamé un mouvement en perlé pour
s'opposer à la réforme ferroviaire du
gouvernement est la mobilisation reprend
pour deux jours demain et jeudi et des
perturbations qui commence dès ce soir à
saint quentin en yvelines le trafic sera
réduit de moitié demain à prévoir 1
train sur 2 sur l'ensemble du réseau
passant par l'agglomération sur les
lignes du rer c les lignes n ai eu du
transilien et vous pouvez rester
informer et consulter les horaires de
vos trains sur le site transilien.com ce
mardi était également une journée de
grève nationale dans la fonction
publique
attrape des professeurs du collège le
village se sont mobilisés ce matin
ils réclament l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
classe dans l'établissement où le nombre
d'élèves augmente les effectifs sont
surchargés une moyenne de 24 élèves par
classe beaucoup trop selon eux pour un
collège de réseau d'éducation
prioritaire et les enseignants demandent
à être traités de façon équitable par
rapport à d'autres collèges de la ville
écouter à ses propos au micro de manon
varaldo et patrick jacques de dixmude a
donc faut savoir qu'au collège on a
parlé salle pour accueillir plus que 24
élèves
on a donc on doit mettre les élèves
contre le tableau et sur des tables
un proviseur et c'est malheureusement le
niveau qui a le plus souffert en termes
de contenus de cours parce qu'elles ont
été gênés par le trop d'élèves à gérer
en même temps ce qui fait qu'on a eu
beaucoup d'exclusion cette année en
quatrième 45 % de nos exclusion de deux
classes c'est simplement pas le niveau
4e qui était qui s'explique je pense
justement par sa part le par le trop
nombre le long trop élevé d'élèves et
les professeurs se sont rendu cet après
midi à versailles pour rencontrer la
direction académique la ds d eux n
indique avec elle rendra une décision
fin juin en fonction du nombre
d'inscriptions s'engager en faveur de
l'afrique un projet d'importance pour
ici divine coopération internationale et
développement vendredi à l'hôtel du
département des yvelines trois
conventions de prêts d'honneur avec des
entrepreneurs yvelinois de la diaspora
africaine ont été signés des aides dans
des projets différents qui seront menées
en afrique pour des engins de chantier à
vocation agricole pour la mise en place
d'une mutuelle santé ou encore pour la
distribution de poisson frais dans les
villages le reportage de manon varaldo
85000 euros c'est le montant de prêts
d'honneur sans intérêt des trois
convention récemment signée le fonds de
prêts d'honneur est financé par yveline
coopération internationale et
développement
toutes ces initiatives verront le jour
au cameroun et au sénégal
dans cette actualité ya diaspora ils ont
participé au développement de l'économie
de notre département n'oublions pas la
vallée de la seine et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui aussi à devoir de retour
vers leur pays d'origine
ces trois initiatives ont été examinés
notamment par l'association à phrase
spécialiste de l'accompagnement et du
financement des entreprises dans les
yvelines
a phase a sélectionné les trois lauréats
suivant plusieurs critères où s'élabore
la viabilité économique d'une part le la
suffisance de financement pour arriver à
atteindre l'objectif est la personnalité
des créateurs on tient beaucoup
l'humain nous sommes pas une banque nous
sommes on fait des prêts d'honneur à une
personne d'ici trois ans ces initiatives
pourront avoir généré 60 emplois au
cameroun et au sénégal et six emplois
dans les yvelines
l'objectif du projet c'est tout
simplement aujourd'hui de permettre un
développement de l'afrique notamment dit
cameron qui sera le pilote pour le
démarrage de ce projet de faciliter
l'accès au plus grand nombre à des
techniques modernes de construction à
des outils mécanisée pour augmenter la
productivité agricole et augmenter
notamment le revenu des petits
agriculteurs
autre projet qui a reçu un prêt
d'honneur de 30000 euros et une bourse
de stage de 5000 euros diaspora santé
l'ambition de cette mutuelle est clair
multiplier par 10 le taux d'accès aux
soins de santé en afrique sur cinq ans
nous faisons le pari que sur les 5,8
millions
des personnes de la diaspora si chacun
prenne en charge un membre de sa famille
nous passés loin de dieu poussant à 21 %
de couverture santé au cameroun
cette assurance santé est ouverte au
cameroun depuis fin 2010 est la côte
d'ivoire le sénégal et la guinée
suivront il ya un peu plus d'un an
emmanuel macron devenait le huitième
président de la vème république le plus
jeune a accédé à la fonction
présidentielle dans l'histoire de france
alors que doit-on retenir de cette
première année de mandat on voit ça tout
de suite avec stéphane minson bonsoir
vous êtes professeur de droit public à
lui vécu l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines également à sciences
po saint germain en laye un hand
emmanuel macron à à l'elysée qu'elle est
la première image qui vous vient en tête
on l'a on l'a qualifié président
jupitérien président des riches
président communicants aussi qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de retenir
moi ce que j'ai envie de retenir à titre
à titre un peu plus institutionnel et
donc peut-être moins politique c'est le
fait qu emmanuel macron s'écouler de
manière extrêmement rapide
étonnamment rapide dans les habits du
président de la vème république de
manière très gaullienne beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus rapidement et de manière
beaucoup plus complète au moins que ses
deux prédécesseurs nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande sait c'est vraiment
pour moi le bilan institutionnelle de
cette première année est vraiment celui
ci il ya d'ailleurs une trentaine de
mesures qui ont été lancés des mesures
d'importance
il va très vite emmanuel macron il va
très vite parce qu'il a le sens du
timing politique
il est faux et abusif de dire qu'il n'a
pas d'expérience politique là où ils
étaient avant il avait il était aux
premières loges pour observer ce qui se
faisait ce qui ne se faisait pas au
demeurant et donc il sait pertinemment
que sur le plan politique les grandes
réformes doivent être engagées dans les
deux premières années du quinquennat et
c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire on
en a parlé lors de votre dernière venue
emmanuel macron a dynamité l'échiquier
politique des partis traditionnels à
gauche et à droite aux abois est ce que
le constat reste le même
aujourd'hui absolument la recomposition
du paysage politique français est encore
à l'oeuvre
regardez regardez ce qui se passe du
côté des anciens partis traditionnels du
côté du parti socialiste avec un premier
secrétaire est quasiment inaudible qui
est contestée en interne
du côté des républicains avec un
président laurent wauquiez qui ne
parvient pas si j'ose dire à imprimer
aux yeux de l'opinion publique et qui de
surcroît est aussi relativement
contestée en interne
quant aux deux autres ensembles
politiques
mélenchon d'un côté marine le pen de
l'autre on voit que ce sont les deux
mouvements qui résistent le mieux mais
j'allais dire c'est tout à fait normal
parce que la république en marche
moore vraiment sûr d'un côté le ps et de
l'autre les républicains donc il est
normal qu émergent aux deux extrémités
ces deux formations politiques je vous
disais tout à l'heure président
communicants on a l'impression que la
mise en scène la mise en scène par don
est sans cesse soigner emmanuel macron
veille sur son image aussi bien sur les
réseaux sociaux à lézinnes termine qu'il
peut donner aux journalistes mais aussi
sur certaines phrases qui ont pu choquer
je vous cite celles ci les gens qui ne
sont rien ce qui qui foutent le bordel
voilà ce sont des citations du président
une stratégie de communication bien
rodée
celle d' emmanuel macron écouter une
stratégie de communication très encadré
qui donne en tout cas l'apparence vous
êtes peut-être presque plus experts que
moi latin mais dans ce domaine mais une
communication qui donne l'air d'être
extrêmement encadrées je pense par
exemple à la mise en scène dès
promulgation des textes de loi vous
savez dans le bureau présidentiel à
l'elysée calqué sur ce qui se fait aux
états unis mais de l'autre une forme de
spontanéité qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celle de nicolas sarkozy avec des
réactions qui peuvent être parfois assez
ville doit être sans doute à juste titre
mais cette c'est la coexistence de cette
communication super cadrer avec cette
forme de spontanéité que j'ai
l'impression emmanuel macron laisse à
devenir comme il le souhaite autant
qu'il le veut qui est assez étonnante
d'ailleurs un autre terme c'est utiliser
ces président des riches alors ça c'est
par ses adversaires en général il ya
quelques réformes impopulaires je pense
à la hausse de la csg qui impacte
directement les retraités le soit aussi
l'a exprimé maillot lac rond de
supprimer l'exit tax qui est un impôt
pour lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
est ce que c'est vraiment le président
des riches c'est en tout cas un
président mais il l'avait annoncé un
président d'essence libérale sur le plan
économique
donc il n'ya pas de ce point de vue de
surprises présent des riches c'est
évidemment un slogan un slogan un slogan
politique qu'on avait vu fleurir aussi
autant de nicolas sarkozy alors on dit
ça va coller au dos de maquereaux
pendant tout son quinquennat c'est pas
certain parce que il reste tout de même
quatre ans pour lui a démontré que le en
même temps à une signification et puis
on peut dire je crois qu emmanuel macron
a fait un pari assez audacieux qui n'est
pas le pari de la redistribution avec le
système français le système social et
économique français fonctionne plutôt
sur le fondement de la redistribution
mais plutôt le pari de l'investissement
en disant si on allège les charges des
entreprises si on entre guillemets
caricature on prend un peu mieux un peu
moins aux riches a bien on pourra avoir
du retour sur investissement avec un
taux d'emploi un peu supérieur donc
alors c'est un pari mais à voir ce qu'il
en adviendra dans les quatre années qui
nous reste à parcourir
dernière chose une contestation sociale
en ce moment qui prend plus ou moins
d'ampleur les cheminots et les
fonctionnaires publics qui sont en tout
cas engagé dans un combat est long et
difficile face au gouvernement est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est la première
grande épreuve du quinquennat est ce
qu'elle va être déterminante pour la
suite du quinquennat
c'est la première grande épreuve de
n'être de cette nature là oui est-ce que
c'est déterminant je n'en suis pas sûr
je pars pourquoi parce que ça n'est pas
prendre à emmanuel macron on a eu
d'autres exemples dans le passé ils sont
suffisamment cité pour le pack non pour
qu'on y revienne pas mais en tout cas je
pense que ça illustre pour une large
part la faiblesse globalement du
dialogue social noyau en france on y
revient toujours mais je crois que c'est
fondamental et notamment la faiblesse
des forces syndicales
contrairement à ce que on peut tant en
percevoir plus je montre mes forces plus
je suis faible en réalité et puis la
faiblesse aussi ça rejoint votre
première question des contre pouvoirs et
des forces d'opposition
on voit émerger les forces d'opposition
les plus extrêmes mais les forces
d'opposition qui seraient les plus
inclusive dans le système c'est à dire
les socialistes d'un côté les
républicains de l'autre nom ne se font
pas entendre et doudou cette crispation
assez forte en ce moment merci à
stéphane mensonge rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de droit public à lui fait
est ce qu est également à sciences po
saint germain en laye lui était
justement adversaire d'emmanuel macron
lors de la présidentielle et cela
faisait à quelques mois qu'il n'avait
plus fait d'apparition publique à saint
quentin en yvelines benoît hamon est
revenu vendredi à la verrière sous la
bannière de son mouvement générations
une réunion publique pour retrouver les
militants et tenter de fédérer la gauche
autour de sa formation nicolas landry
c'est un retour dans les yvelines pour
benoît hamon une réunion publique à la
verrière dans son ancienne
circonscription des militants du
mouvement générations point s des
sympathisants de gauche des curieux plus
de 200 personnes ont assisté à ce rendez
vous je voulais voir un petit peu ce que
benoît
on propose et quelle est sa réaction par
rapport au régime présidentiel moi
vraiment c'est le programme de benoît
vraiment déjà des idées
le côté humain aussi écologique au
revenu universel développement
écologique ou encore création d'outils
démocratiques innovants les idées de
benoît hamon le fondateur de génération
point elle soit aussi à l'horizon les
élections municipales de 2020 je
m'appliquerai je m'appliquerai lors des
échéances municipales pour essayer de de
favoriser ou le passage de certaines
communes à gauche ou le maintien
d'autres
céret de faciliter à la fois l'union et
le rassemblement et puis vraiment le
grand renouvellement aussi ddd du
paysage politique sur son territoire
ayant une dynamique déjà enclenché sur
le territoire avec près de 800 adhérents
yvelinois exemple avec le conseil
municipal de la verrière composé de
membres de génération point s malgré une
majorité communiste ont su que je suis
communiste donc effectivement j'ai une
analyse et une analyse politique est
différente de celle de benoît bien sûr
après la gauche et est multiple et on a
besoin de tout l'est de toutes les
sensibilités
pour
réunir le maximum de monde autour d'une
autre politique
un appel au rassemblement de la gauche
avant 2019 et les élections européennes
à l'an passé les utilisateurs de deux
roues motorisés ont payé un lourd tribut
96 morts en ile-de-france soit 30 % de
personnes tuées sur les routes de la
région c'est pour enrayer ces
statistiques et sensibiliser sur le
sujet avec est organisée en ce moment la
quinzaine régionale des usagers
vulnérables
un événement dédié aux deux roues
motorisés mais aussi aux cyclistes et
piétons un message véhiculé dans cette
vidéo vous voyez à l'écran game over
l'attention doit être réciproque entre
l'automobiliste et le motard est dans le
cadre de cette quinzaine d actions sont
programmées à notamment dans les
yvelines
c'est un rôle difficile au quotidien
être aidant familial est vécue comme une
tâche lourde et le soutien de ces
personnes confrontées à la maladie de
leur proche se présente comme nécessaire
l'institut de promotion de la santé de
saint quentin en yvelines propose un
accompagnement aux aidants
bonsoir anne baekeland on soit elle vous
êtes chargé de projet santé publique ali
ps institut de promotion de la santé
alors l'institut propose des actions
l'une d'entre elles c'est l'entrée dans
café le prochain qui se déroule le 30
mai à l'espace auriol aux
clayes-sous-bois on va y venir dans un
instant un mot d'abord sur lies ps
quelles sont ses missions
alors le lit ps est donc le service
santé de saint quentin en yvelines et
ses principales missions c'est de
réduire les inégalités de santé les
inégalités sociales de mettre en place
des actions de prévention pour
accompagner les saint quentinois
dans ce qui peut être le commanditaire
le l'accompagnement des j'ai eu beaucoup
de mal au poignet notamment les églises
notamment les actions des doses et
danser aussi prévenir justement
l'épuisement des personnes proches
aidants donc accompagner les aidants
beaucoup de personnes n'ont pas
conscience d'être aidant à partir de
quel moment on peut considérer qu'on est
con et tu es dans qu'est ce qui définit
finalement les dons alors c'est vrai que
les aidants ne se reconnaissent pas
forcément en tant que tels ils sont
d'abord époux parents enfants frères
soeurs ce qui définit un aidant c'est en
fait l'accompagnement qu'ils vont faire
auprès de leurs proches atteints d'une
maladie invalidante ou qui souffrent
d'un handicap donc l'aide elle peut
prendre plusieurs formes
c'est d'abord une aide un soutien
psychologique et morale une aide
organisationnelle dans les tâches de la
vie domestique
c'est aussi une préoccupation que l'on
peut avoir parce qu'on s'inquiète voilà
de la santé sont proches savoir comment
va se dérouler la journée où les jours à
venir
donc en fait ça peut prendre plusieurs
formes et est souvent dans la plupart
des cas les aidant à sur toutes ces
tâches et et tout s'est tu
ce soutien on imagine un accompagnant
primordial le l'aidant peut souffrir
d'isolement en tout cas se sentir isolé
face à la maladie du proche
il a besoin d'être aidé oui il a besoin
d'être soutenue parce que comme vous le
dites il souffre de solitude il est
souvent mal compris c'est quelquefois
difficile de parler de la maladie de son
proche
tant qu'on n'est pas la place de
l'aidant c'est aussi quelquefois
difficile de se représenter ce que peut
être
l'accompagnement au quotidien d'un
proche malade ou en situation de
handicap un seul bureau ça que je sais
c'est quoi coke et de prendre du temps
pour soi c'est de se ménager aussi les
dents souvent cumul et fatigue morale et
fatigue physique et les dents doit
accompagner dans le long terme donc les
actions de soutien aux aidants sont là
pour justement proposer une palette dead
une palette d'outils
dans laquelle peut puiser les dents pour
avoir toute forme de soutien et je vais
pouvoir peut-être développé avec vous
sur les entraînements qui a fait
justement qui est l'une de ces actions
finalement quelle est l'idée derrière
tel est l'objectif d'une telle alors les
objectifs sont multiples c'est à la fois
rencontrer des pères pour se sentir
moins seuls et partager aussi ses
difficultés
quelle que soit la maladie puisque
l'idée de ses entrées dans café c'est de
se faire se rencontrer des gens non pas
par le prisme d'une maladie spécifique
ou d'un type de handicap mais plutôt de
réunir des aidants pour de leur point de
vue des dents ils puissent partager
leurs difficultés rencontrées des
professionnels aussi prendre des
informations qui leur permettent de
connaître les dispositifs existants les
aides sur lesquels s'appuyait ces
pratiques à chaque fois alors ce sont
des thématiques qui sont effectivement
variés qui changent d'une rencontre à
l'autre qui sont souvent proposés par
les indiens eux-mêmes parce qu'ils
recherchent une information spécifique
sur va par exemple quels sont les les
protections juridiques qui peuvent être
un outil d'accompagnement pour eux mais
ils sont là aussi pour se rencontrer et
traiter de leur problématique des dents
c'est à dire de quoi l'avenir va être
fait je suis préoccupé où je me sens
agressif en ce moment où je suis
traversé par un sentiment de
découragement
donc tous ces sujets vont pouvoir être
traitées et à chaque fois l'intervenant
expert dans son domaine
d'intervention va apporter la de
l'information et répondre aux questions
des participants
vous en parlais juste avant ces cafés
font partie d'une stratégie finalement
plus globale il ya plusieurs actions qui
sont menées par lee ps pour accompagner
les aidants quel type d'accompagnement
ça va se faire part du groupe de parole
par exemple par exemple c'est à dire que
les entrées dans café sont une des
actions qui constituent le programme
global de soutien
ça va pouvoir répondre à certaines à
certains besoins en tout cas à certaines
personnes
et puis en complément de ces actions là
il y a deux types d'actions les groupes
de paroles qui sont des groupes d espace
2 2d coûte mais aussi des espaces où
l'on peut déposer une parole un peu plus
confidentiels dans un cadre plus
confidentielle encore une fois que les
cafés qui sont comment comme des cafés
de ville c'est à dire on partage bien
sûr la parole mais il ya des
consommateurs qui sont environ 90 des
poses pas la même parole et puis en
complément de ces deux actions il ya
aussi les ateliers d'y pratiquer ou là à
la demande des aidants il a été mis en
place des ateliers autour de 2 du
ressourcement de la détente du bien-être
à travers plusieurs types d'actions donc
si on résume
c'est une aide à la fois psychologiques
aussi logistique était apportée à ces
aidants alors c'est avant tout une aide
en terme d'information c'est à dire que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place
pour que les aidants se sentent moins
démunis sache qui appelait et dans
quelle situation
c'est une aide sous forme de soutien
moral et psychologique à travers
certains thèmes des rencontres dans le
café mais aussi des groupes de parole et
puis c'est une aide à travers le comment
on peut prendre un petit peu de temps
pour soi comment on peut se faire du
bien aussi s'échapper un petit peu avant
du temps de répit avec ou sans son
proche et de manière à pouvoir partager
un temps autour vraiment dû encore une
fois du ressourcement du plaisir du
partage avec d'autres
la dernière chose comment peut-on se
faire accompagner lorsqu'on était donc
en prendre contact avec les ps alors lis
ps c'est assez facile de de prendre
contact avec il ya un numéro peut-être
qu'il va s'afficher sur votre écran un
numéro de téléphone un site internet je
crois qu'ils s'affichent dans le site
internet de saint quentin en yvelines
et sinon je peux peut-être donné le
numéro de l'accueil de lits ps qui
pourra répondre à toutes ces questions
sur ses actions d'aidé aux aidants c'est
le 01 30 16 17 80 on précise que ces
rencontres sont gratuites
alors c'est totalement gratuit parce que
financée en partie par
l'agpm qui est une association privée
qui oeuvrent pour mettre en place des
actions de soutien en direction des
aidants aussi par la conférence des
financeurs qui est présidé par le
département
et puis bien sûr par saint quentin en
yvelines il rappelle que le prochaine
entrée dans café c'est le 30 mai à
l'espace sauriol des clayes-sous-bois de
10h à 12h et vous pouvez retrouver la
liste complète des actions lee ps ans
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci al baekeland
d'abord est avec mais je vous en prie je
rappelle que vous êtes chargé de projet
santé publique à l'institut de promotion
de la santé de saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup mais on reste à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette
opération a attiré au niveau national
plus de 2 millions de visiteurs le
succès de la nuit européenne des musées
se confirme avec et des visiteurs à
l'heure où d'habitude les portes sont
closes le musée de la ville jouait lui
aussi les prolongations animations et
visites guidées étaient au programme
retour sur la soirée avec mélanie poker
je voudrais vous voit
devant la première diffusion de lille ou
d'enfants le musée a fait son show télé
pour cette nuit des musées le thème
était tout trouvé
la télévision le sujet de l'exposition
temporaire du musée de la ville c'est
une proposition convivial et plus
festive que ce qu'on peut proposer
d'habitude dans un musée c'est
l'occasion de faire venir au musée et
d'un public de jeunes adultes qu'on
touche un peu moins peut-être que
d'autres établissements en
fonctionnement normal et la nuit des
musées l'aurait vraiment destinée des
improvisations de déclic théâtre des
visites guidées le temps d'une soirée le
public a délaissé sa télévision pour se
plonger dans l'histoire celle du petit
écran
c'est l'occasion de sortir le soir en
famille de visiter un musée dans un
contexte dans un contexte un peu
différent eh ben j'ai vu les télés
d'avant qui avait quitte pas du tout la
même chose que d'habitude c'est plus
pratique et aussi ses plus beaux et
parce que j'étais pas très belle avant
l'été c'était grosse pour partager un
moment en famille et puis c'est pas tous
les jours que le musée ouvert le soir
donc c'est bien c'est une bonne occasion
de sortir le soir dans un esprit
culturel à 23h fin des programmes le
musée de la ville a retrouvé son calme
après avoir accueilli 454 visiteurs
avant la prochaine nuit on referme ce
journal sur une rencontre musicale le
portrait de la semaine est consacrée à
salomé et le lui connu dans le milieu de
la nuit sous le pseudonyme de poppy de
paris-7 versaillaise était avant dans la
communication elle est devenue djette en
2016 miquel et demi d'euros elle a suivi
lors d'un mix à paris qui regardez
[Musique]
de londres à paris salomé le lui 28 ans
fait danser les fêtards depuis deux ans
une passion pour le monde de la nuit qui
n'est ici dans les yvelines pendant son
adolescence à versailles
déjà à l'époque j'étais j'étais fan de
musique bon comme beaucoup l'ont mais
j'étais déjà à créer des playlists de
tous types
voilà je veux passer des après midi
entière à faire ça donc je vous ai pas
très loin du château de versailles et du
coup cerveau mémoire planches c'est
beaucoup d'émotions
et plein de plein d'ondés positives
salomé le lui c'est aujourd'hui
transformé en poppy de paris son surnom
dans le milieu et gagne environ 500
euros par soirée pour les préparer cette
fan de vanessa paradis crée ses
playlists sur une après midi quelques
jours à l'avance avec une idée en tête
faire danser essayez d'imaginer ce que
les gens ont envie d'entendre à cet
instant précis
donc voilà l'idée c'est pas de rester de
se dire tiens je vais à cette soirée je
vais mixer ça ça ça en fait ça se passe
jamais comme ça il ya vraiment un
travail d'analysé de
et et dans taxi je dirais même parce que
il faut se mettre à la place des gens
faut pas se dire tiens moi j'ai envie
d'écouter ça c'est pas un métier mais
vos histoires pour devenir crédible
l'ancienne étudiante en communication a
dû également apprendre à dompter les
capricieuses table de mixage sans
formation au déluge de tâter les moutons
un peu même si j'ai je me suis entraîné
il ya toujours des ratés il ya toujours
des moments où tu te dis à lhassa sonner
faux
et justement en fait c'est c'est
vraiment typiquement le métier où il
faut pratiquer un maximum pour
s'améliorer
ce soir là la djette a pu se tester
devant plusieurs dizaines de personnes
dans un restaurant chic parisien du 2e
arrondissement
j'ai vu des gens qui arrivent et qui
poseraient les petites souris
salomé a fini son animation à une heure
du matin une soirée qu'il aura
certainement rapprocher encore un peu
plus de ses rêves
mixer sur la plage et pourquoi pas sur
l'île indonésienne de bali
[Musique]
c'est la fin du set 8 journal cette
édition et tous ces reportages sont à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 belle soirée à
tous
[Musique]